what are you doing sir hi my name is
Brittany and I'm gonna be fostering a
dog in a cat this week I'm in between
jobs right now so I have a ton of extra
time I love animals I would love the
opportunity to give them a loving home
even if it's only for a short time for
the last eight years we had a little pup
named scooter and he just passed away in
June I'm hoping to learn if my boyfriend
and I are ready to take on a pet we do a
good job of keeping our household
running but we're gonna introduce two
new elements that require a lot of care
and attention I think it's gonna be some
sort of an emotional experience because
like we haven't had any animals in the
house since Squier you don't know
anything about the cat and dog that I'm
fostering this week but I'm excited to
find out so also in blondie and I have
been hanging out for a few hours now and
it's going pretty well and you can see
Blondie's chillin just behind me here
also is walking around exploring here he
is he's having a good time
and he likes to play
you're gonna get this guy out of his
shell soon enough an arse boy sure is
doing funny it started off a little
difficult it definitely didn't seem like
looks new just like how to be a dog I
remember us just trying to take him out
for his horse walk he was confused about
things like walks like playing with toys
what's what's the Biloxi was used to do
by day two they've completely consumed
our lifestyle because we've learned that
also needs eyes on him at all times he
had completely cute a hole through our
sheets another day of trying to get
locked out of his crate we're gonna try
and coax him up boy by day three I
definitely was falling in love move even
though I was such a handful it was so
fun having animals around we found out
that Lux was brought in from a hoarding
situation and people who handled him
were very aggressive toward him which is
why he's so traumatized he's doing it
awesome finally as toys he needs to
excited blondie has some toys too
I thought like I'm such a dog person I'm
gonna be ready to take him on and I
realize now it's probably not the right
time but something else that I realize
is that I may be more of a cat person
than I thought I was I didn't think I
was that interested in cats but then I
was head over heels for blondie his
sweet little angel she's nappin
so it's luck seized last date today and
he has grown tremendously he's had a
couple very positive run-ins with other
dogs I think the week of fostering has
given Lux a chance to try and understand
what it's like to be a dog since he
hasn't really had that before and char
he just had like a nice place to hang
it's been such a good experience fast
ring for the first time it went better
than I could have possibly imagined
except for the fact that I fell in love
with two little animals that I really
don't want to give up down blondie on my
left yeah I feel like we've definitely
fulfilled the goal of okay there's been
other animals in the house and scooter
and it's different but it's not that
different like it's still great we did
not go into this thinking that we were
going to adopt I've had at all but being
head over heels for blondie we decided
that we wanted to adopt her blondie we
love you so much and we want to keep
[Music]